Have you watched Rick and Morty?
No,
I haven't.
Many people have told me to watch Rick
and Morty,
although they said it's very dark and
well that doesn't bother me so much I
suppose.
Although I'm plenty dark perhaps without
adding too much.
So,
but um,
I would like to watch it and I probably
will.
So I would love for you to do come and
do a talk in Montreal.
Well,
you never know what that might happen.
I've been talking to God side of bolt
out a fair bit.
You know,
he's coming to Toronto November 11th so
we can do the talk.
That was shut down by Ryerson back in
August.
So I'm looking forward to that.
So
what's the best way to stop drinking
alcohol and start doing my best in my
psychology degree,
it's affecting my study,
but I can do very well if I stop.
I'm 26.
Well,
Paul,
what I would say is I think you should
do the future authoring program and you
should really concentrate.
There's a section in it that helps you
determine what your positive view of
your future would be,
but another section that helps you
determine what would happen in your life
if you're negative habits got out of
control.
And one of the things that can really
help you control your alcohol intake is
to really,
really think through what you're giving
up and where you could be in five years
if you don't get it under control.
And proclivity to alcoholism can be a
really vicious thing.
You know,
lots of people get dragged down into the
mud by alcohol excess alcohol intake,
especially if they're sensitive to the
opiate response that alcohol can
produce.
You can tell that if you,
when you drink,
you know,
you get alert and,
and,
and uh,
let's say more enthusiastic and
energetic and then you don't want to
stop drinking.
That's uh,
that's definitely a bad sign with
regards to developing alcoholism.
So I would say you need to figure out
something that's,
that's more important to you,
that drinking and also think through
very hard.
The negative consequences of continuing
it.
You're,
you're at about the age 26 where you
should stop.
I mean guys who are going to stop
generally start slow down pretty,
pretty intensely around that age.
Um,
you know,
get also treating your psychology,
studying as a full time job can also be
helpful.
So,
you know,
get up at eight in the morning or seven
30 in the morning and start hitting the
books by nine and put in a six to eight
hour day.
And then even if you do keep drinking,
at least you're moving forward.
So that's what I can say about the APP.
Are you a science fiction fan?
You referenced timelines,
starship troopers in a lecture,
and your ideas often remind me of Harry
Selden's plan from Asimov's foundation
series.
Hey,
well,
when I was a kid,
which is quite a long time ago now,
um,
I lived in this town called Fairview,
Alberta,
which was a town of about 3000 people
way the hell north 350 miles northwest
of Edmonton.
And I have this neighbor across the
street across the Ellie actually,
and he had a huge science fiction
library.
It must've been,
I dunno,
5,000 books there,
1970s,
1960s,
1970s classics,
like Heinlein and Asimov.
And he would let me go over there and
take like 20 books at a time.
And I was reading about a book a day at
that point.
And I read science fiction like mad
probably till I was about 19 or so,
and maybe a little younger than that and
then turn more to classic literature
when I got to college.
And,
and,
uh,
also partly as a consequence of some
lessons that the local library and
taught me about what to read.
So I was a science fiction fan.
Um,
I haven't read science fiction for a
very long time,
although I was pretty happy with it when
I was a kid.
So.